Wow school of life changed my life
people will help you with your problems
but there are only few who will teach
you how to solve your own problems and
lilamon knows how to make you enable so
that you can find answers to your own
questions she either personally or
professionally and Lily she's an amazing
person she gives us over 100% to the
program she's there for you I am going
to be relaunching my School of Life
program starting May 22nd the last time
I ran this program I saw lives being
changed
I saw breakthroughs being made I saw
ideas turn into businesses and I'm gonna
do it all over again
why because I want you guys to start
building a life and business that has
meaning and purpose so I hope you guys
are ready because I'm ready and let's do
this so I've coached hundreds of people
from around the world and I've seen the
common patterns of things that hold
people back I also have the tools and
solutions to help them create their best
life so I've taken everything that I
know and have learned as a coach and I
put it together in this nine-week course
just for you so I made the School of
Life at these three reasons the first
one is to have an immersion program
which means that you're going to be
working intensely for nine weeks you're
gonna have homework you know work
extremely hard towards building a life
that you rightfully deserve because how
many times have you had sparks of
inspiration
and motivation after reading a book or
doing a course or watching a youtube
video only not to follow through now I'm
keeping this small for a reason I'm only
going to work with nine of you so I'm
gonna give it everything that I got to
make sure that you come out of this
course transformed the second reason is
to build a community because I
understand that the journey towards
personal development and
entrepreneurship can be a lonely one and
we're much more likely to succeed when
we have people around us who care about
us and cheering us on so you can have an
opportunity to do that through our
Facebook community or you can share a
learn and hold each other accountable
and you will also have direct access to
me for additional support the last
reason is the affordability normally for
my coaching I charge $100 US per hour
while I have seen the lives of my
clients change I also recognize that
paying $100 in an hour is not affordable
for everyone which is why I created the
School of Life because I wanted to give
you the tools to create your best life
without paying the regular price so
you're probably wondering to yourself
what is in the School of Life so the
program is divided into these three
different modules number one if
discovering your inner self it is time
to let go of who you think you should be
and really step into who you truly are
and we're gonna do so by doing these
three different things number one is
finding out your one word which is a
single most important core value defined
by you you're also going to write a
credo which is your personal mission
statement to living the life that you
number two we're going to learn how to
apply your one word and Quino to the
three most important aspects of your
life and lastly we're going to develop
an action plan that is achievable with
specific timelines to make sure that you
start to build a life that you really
want
number two is get rid of those limiting
beliefs when you discover who you truly
are and what it is that you want out of
life and you're ready to make your next
bold move chances are you are going to
get in your own way and the reason for
that is because you have years and years
and years of limiting beliefs holding
you back the voices that talk to you
telling you that you're not good enough
that it's not going to happen
you have failed before what makes you
think that you're not gonna fail again
or you have a terrible relationship with
money in fact I want to share a personal
story from Alexandra who's one of the
students of school of life and how she
was able to overcome her limiting
beliefs around money and start creating
a business that really mattered to her
so here she is enjoying so I had a
limited believe about money I was always
saying you know what I don't have a
limit the believes I would say that but
deep down I was conscious that I have a
limited belief because I don't have that
mom that much money that I want and I
could never find the correlation and
connection between my actual situation
money situation and my beliefs
Lily helped me find that connection
through her exercises and everything we
were doing and brainstorming and
rewriting and thinking and remembering I
could neck that when I was a little girl
I remember that I was always saving from
my everything that you know somebody
gave you money or you have to go to
school and something I would save a
little bit and I would always buy some
presents for other I was always doing
something for others everybody around me
my family my friends they always say oh
she
she could person she's always giving and
she always cares about others so that
stuck in my mind because I was really
proud proud of myself so I wanted to be
that more often so as I was growing up I
was only giving giving giving now I'm
still giving and I'm all about of course
you should give but you should get to
the point where you can not cross that
wall I realized that in my mind if I
have money that means that I'm not
giving because if I have money I should
give it away so if I have money I'm not
giving and I am NOT a good person it's
such a powerful powerful belief that I
had you probably have the same limiting
belief right now around money that you
are not a good person if you don't have
money or money's the only thing that
matters or you're not good enough to
receive the money whatever it is is
holding you back from living the life
that you really want like Alexandra I
was holding herself back from creating a
coaching business that was so meaningful
and so purposeful for her so it's time
to put an end to that so in this section
I'm gonna go over three different things
to get rid of your limiting beliefs
number one is to really identify what
they are to begin with through some
reflective exercises number two is to
figure out the root cause of them so we
could really dig in deep and really
break it at the roots and lastly is to
replace all of those negative thinking
patterns with positive actions you're
also going to learn how to set up
triggers in your environment so that way
you don't have to think about being
courageous every single day it's already
automatic for you number three is
contribution and impact once you have
the ability to change your own life now
you have the responsibility to help
other people and create a ripple effect
throughout your entire
unity it's great to achieve your goals
and to live your life on your own terms
but I believe that the truth fulfillment
comes from contributing to others and
giving back however that looks like for
you whether if it's helping your family
and friends to your co-workers or
building a business that could change
the world either way you have the
responsibility to contribute back and
we're going to do so by number one
discovering what is a contribution that
you want to provide to this world and
number two is find your own unique way
to spread your message so each week
we're going to meet for two hours I'm
going to introduce a new topic we're
gonna work through some practical
exercises together and you're gonna
leave other 24 mission which is a
tailored assignment to help you get
started right away you will also have a
weekly action plan to help you carry
through to the following week I will
also leave time for each session for you
to ask me specific questions as well as
get feedback regarding your progress you
will also have an option to add a
30-minute one-on-one coaching sessions
with me on a weekly basis you're gonna
have assignments progress reports and a
Facebook group to make sure they stay on
the right track because it's just it's
amazing to me how much people are
willing to give to the jobs that they
hate to the bosses that they hate but
not willing to give to themselves
because once we commit ourselves to
someone else who are much more likely to
follow through the School of Life is for
you this is about living the life on
your own terms and building a life that
you rightfully deserve so you've got me
as your coach and I'm going to show you
on and you know I am NOT going to let
you off the hook so the school of life
is going to take place every single
Tuesday from 7:00 to 9:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
starting a main twenty-second for my
one-on-one coaching and charged $100 per
hour however for this entire program is
going to cost you two hundred and forty
seven dollars which includes the 18 hour
group coaching plus the
plus having direct access to me via
email you will also have the option to
do a bundle rate to add an additional 30
minute one-on-one coaching session with
me on a weekly basis for four hundred
and seventy-five dollars so for those of
you who are interested in transforming
your life please send me an email
at lilia and Evan Carmichael comm now I
only have nine spots it's going to be an
intimate experience so if you are
interested please email me right away I
am so incredibly excited to go on this
journey with you and let's get started
in building your best life and I'll see
you in class thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you guys very very
soon raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your it's
something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details